don't bring anyone love into this should
we try giving top dog a call yeah yeah
what what are we gonna ask him about
anything in part of him caught up in a
while you know sure I love talking him
yeah I miss him I know I'm he's supposed
to come out gonna answer he's my
favorite bad at answering hey Dad
buddy hey what are you doing I'm driving
back from oh yeah how was it Oh straight
you know yeah absolutely the same
conversation every time I go out there
yeah nothing ever changes you say the
same thing and then paint job he's still
a total animal
right we go to that what that he's still
a total animal oh yeah he spilled the
soup offering stop for lunch today
yeah how'd your uh then how was how does
driving like cuz that's a good Drive how
does that affect your going to the
bathroom does that make you go more or
less or how does it affect you well you
know I I made sure where I left the
hotel this morning drive up to see him
yeah I dropped another look okay yeah
and then when we left a lot too had a
mini load so I've had bombs away three
times today and what what kind of
consistency though well the third one
really was a blast
the first one was okay I hit the road it
like 7:30 in the morning then I'm
totally screwed after today oh really
yeah so are you drinking McDonald's
coffee on your way you know home is that
what you do you stop there get a coffee
oh yeah go the drive get a coffee yeah
three creams - three creams - splendid
just find another drop oh and it's the
best coffee right that's why you're
so much me yeah it's such good
coffee but you shouldn't drink on fee as
you're driving yeah I know it's probably
gonna make you more hey I wanted
out you were at sea on a cruise when
that horrific hurricane came through how
was that what was that experience like
being at sea during that well because we
we were on the south side of Cuba and
the storm was kind of coming through the
north side you know on the northeast
side there that is like the ultimate
barrier reason you have whole island in
between so we didn't get a single wait
okay it was calm as you can get you know
yeah my big concern was I parked my car
on the ground floor yeah in Miami of the
Miami group of course I'm watching TV
and I'm thinking that my car's gonna get
flooded I even called the insurance
company from the ship just you know me
just to check the protocol on how do you
well you're not going to believe and
then I hear we can't get in Miami
because there's a sunken sailboat well
wait what did they tell you was the
protocol water comes up on the rocker
panels yeah Wow
how how was the cruise food-wise and and
and you know dumping wise for you
routine they're basically you know you
can eat a little bit more on cruise ship
so basically two or three a day I
probably in the extent of the cruise I'm
not
$25 on the cruise
I counted the whole week Wow hey would
you would you be willing I found a
seminar where they can teach you to
orgasm from hugging someone would you go
to it if I sent you to it with mom you
know I think I mean there was a time
when I was in high school that I could
orgasm without not getting anybody okay
yeah but would you like to learn
would you like to learn this tantric
technique with mom that would be fun
that would be really exciting right I
will I'll get all the details and send
you guys and if you guys want to go
it'll be all expenses paid okay so if
you want to go okay so we'll do some
research you know you let us know if you
want to go Hey supposed to yeah it's
supposed to really you know enhance
things so just I'm just thinking about
it but look I have to run I love you
I'll call you in a little while okay
I think he was more excited about the
all-expenses-paid card yeah I'm good and
then like I'll pay for he's like wow
he'll be neat now is it in Florida I
have no I mean I have no idea where I
wonder where I will look it up and if
they teach a thing I always thought I
would send them yeah we just have to
have a crew follow them around he's so
funny yeah yeah I would love to see my
folks reporting on that because like my
debut like it's kind of goofy and my mom
would just be like I'm so disgusted so
grace it's okay to be disgusting yeah
disgusting Tracy yeah
[Music]